so far we've introduced bayesian
networks and talked about how to perform
inference in them in this module we'll
turn to the question of how to learn
them from
so recall that a bayesian network
consists of a set of random variables
for example
of cold allergies
off
and itchy eyes
the bayesian network also comes equipped
with a dag specifying the qualitative
relationships between all these
different variables
quantitatively however the bayesian
network defines
a set of local conditional distributions
over each variable x i given the parents
of i
and in this example we would have
probability of c given parents which are
none probability of a probability of h
given its two parents c and a and
probability of i given a
so finally if we multiply all of these
probability distributions together
then we get
what is the joint distribution all
random variables in this case we have a
c
a
h
and i
then there's a question of how you do
inference in asian networks so inference
remember you're given the bayesian
network you're given some evidence that
you observe for example h and i equals
one and one over a subset of the
variables and then you're given a query
variable which is something that you're
interested in let's say you
hold
and the inference algorithm is going to
produce
a distribution over your query variables
condition on evidence
so for every possible setting of the
query variable we have a probability
so we saw many ways of doing this
including manually by exhaustive
enumeration
we can convert major networks into
markup networks and do give sampling and
then for hmms we have specialized
techniques such as the forward backward
algorithm and particle filtering
so inference assumes that all these
local conditional distributions are
known
but the big question is where did all
these come from
so all these numbers are called the
parameters of the bayesian network the
red question marks and in general we
might not know what they are
so let's try to learn them so again in
all learning tasks we start with the
data so in this case the training data
is going to include
examples where each example is a
complete assignment to x so this is the
fully supervised setting which is the
simplest one to start out with
and then the learning algorithm is going
to produce parameters and the parameters
are exactly all these red question marks
these are all the local conditional
probabilities
so
we're going to go through a bunch of
examples and then later show a general
principle that ties all of them together
so you might be feeling a little bit um
that this this might be very challenging
because probabilistic inference assumes
you know the parameters and it was
already pretty hard both computationally
and perhaps conceptually even
but it turns out that for bayesian
networks at least somewhat surprising if
you're learning under fully supervised
data learning actually turns out to be
surprisingly easy
so let's begin
so suppose you're developing vision
networks to model how
people rate movies
so um let's start with the world's
simplest page network which has one
variable r which represents the rating
of a movie so the joint distribution is
just p r in this case
the movie rating can be one two five
so first we have to
identify what the parameters are so the
parameters here theta is just the
probability of one probability of two
probably three part of a four
probability of five
there are five parameters and if you're
a little bit clever you only need four
of them because the five numbers have to
sum to one but for the sake of
simplicity let's just say that there's
five parameters
okay and now you're given some training
data
some ratings from users you have a one
you have a three i have a bunch of fours
and three fives
and now the question is how do you
estimate the parameters given the
training data
let's just follow our notes here well
intuitively you would think that the
probability of a rating
is a proportional to the number of
occurrences
of that particular rating in the
training data
so now this is just intuition um
it might be a good thing or it might not
be a good thing well let's find out
later but let's just go with that for
now
so here's the training data and what i'm
going to do
um is the parameters are a
probability table so we're going to see
a lot of these over the course of the
next few slides so for every rainy i'm
going to count number of times it shows
up 1 shows up once
2 shows up 0 times 3 shows up once
four shows up five times
and five shows up three times
and now i'm just going to
sum up all the counts that gives me 10
i'm going to normalize to get my
probabilities
and that's the probabilistment that's it
count and normalize
okay so let's um
level up a little bit and talk about two
variables suppose that
um now the rating is governed by the
genre so in particular the asian network
is you first generate the genre and then
you generate the rating given genre
so now there's um
the parameters of this bayesian network
includes both the probability of the
genre which can two parameters and the
probability of rating given genre which
includes
two times five parameters so 10
parameters for a total of 12 parameters
again if you're being clever you can get
that down to nine
so now we're giving some training data
so we have um each training a point
remember is a full assignment all the
variables so we have our g equals d and
r equals four here
so now
how do we estimate the parameters given
this more complicated
network
so following our nodes again there's
intuitive strategy is that we're just
going to estimate each local conditional
distribution separately and see what
happens okay so what does that mean that
means for
probability of
g
i'm just going to count the number of
times
particular values of g show up so d
shows up uh one two three times
and c shows up twice so notice that this
is the kind of same calculation as we
had before
so now this is three fits and two fits
if you sum up and normalize
okay so in estimating p of g i simply
only look at the slice of the examples
that matter for this
and same with a
probability of
r given g so now i'm going to look at
all the possible
assignments to
the parent of a particular
a node and also that node so that's a g
and r so
d4
shows up twice
e5 shows up once c1 shows up once and c5
shows up once
now i count and normalize and i get my
probability estimate of r
and g
okay so far so good so
in summary
consider each local conditional
distribution separately and then count
based on the slice of the data that's
matters and normalize
so now let's um consider three variables
um so we have a genre whether the movie
won an award or not and the rating
so here we have a genre and whether it
won award influencing whether um how
well the movie is rated joint
distribution is p of g p of a p of r
given g n a
so now we have
local conditional distributions for each
of these
factors here
so remember that v structures
this type of structure was really
special in bayesian networks it gives
rise to explaining away
it's a thing that if you marginalize
unobserved leaves you render things come
independent
and it was really a hallmark of visual
but from a perspective of learning
there's really nothing special here
and uh to see this what we're gonna do
is just um you know suppose we have some
training data which concludes
assignments to all three variables
um we're just going to count and
normalize again okay so
here
um we're going to start with p of g
this is exactly the same thing as before
we just look at only the genre
and then we're going to look at um
here a which is analogously looking at
only
0 1 0
1
and counting and normalizing and now the
the big local conditional distribution
is p of r
given g and a so here i'm going to look
at
the parents of r
and r itself i'm going to count the
number of times this local configuration
happens so i have d01
showing up once uh d03
um
going up once
um
and d15 showing up once
and each of these showing once and now
now i want to normalize so i have to be
a little bit careful i don't want to add
all these numbers and normalize because
this is
um
conditioned on
g and a
so that means for every
uh
g and setting of g and a i have my a
distribution over r
i'm gonna look at d zero
so i have uh r um one occurrence of r
equals one and one occurrence of r
equals three so that's
if i normalize that it's going to give
me a half and a half
and now for
this setting g and a i only have one
possibility of r so that has probability
one and same for these other ones
so again everything is count and
normalize where you have to pay
attention to what you're normalizing
over you're only normalizing over
possible
values of r
not g and a
so one thing you might note is that
a lot of these probabilities are
one and the probabilities that are not
mentioned here are zero so you might
wonder that if this is a good estimate
but we'll come back to that later
so um now let's invert the b structure
let's look at a different
structure so we have the genre and
suppose we have two people jim and
martha and they're both going to rate
this movie and both of them rated
depending on the genre so g generates r1
and also generates r2
so now we have this three uh node page
network
and um the estimation is going to
be the same i'll just go through it very
quickly so we have parameters one for
every variable here
and so
probability of
g
is count to normalize
probability of
r1
given g
is you count and normalize again
remember that
i'm normalizing over
possible values of g so you can
partition the rows based on the value of
g so here i have
two and one and i'm normalizing two
thirds and one thirds and g equals c is
just handled uh separately
in a separate normalization
and then um
[Music]
r2 given g is analogous so i'm not going
to go over this
so this is fine um
except for what i'm going to now do is
think
about the setting where suppose you have
not just two users but a thousand users
or a million users now you might be a
little bit worried because now for every
user you might have to
have its own have their own
local conditional distribution
and the number of parameters might just
blow up which means that um estimation
might be hard especially for new users
so we're going to consider a slightly
different um
it's going to be the same
bayesian network here
but
the the parameters are different
in particular i'm going to consider
um a single parameter of r given g
instead of having p r 1 and p of r 2.
so now how do i estimate
distribution of this model
so
let's begin so
probability of g is the same as before
and now the probability of r given g
i'm just going to count the number of
times
a particular local configuration shows
up
either where r is r1 or r2 so d3 shows
up
once here
d4 shows up
three times you have one
and
two and three so notice i'm counting
both uh currencies of r1 and r2
and d5 shows up twice um
here
with r1 and here with r2
um c1 shows up once a c2 shows up one c
or shows up once and c5 shows up once as
well
um now
i just count and normalize so i look at
all the
e's and i count from sum and normalize
and i look at all the of c's
i count normalize
okay so when i have only one
distribution
that is responsible for two nodes i
simply aggregate their counts and
normalize
so this is
an important slide so the more general
idea that i want to highlight is this
idea of parameter sharing and base
networks
and this happens when the local
conditional distributions over different
variables
are actually
the same
and to be very precise about that i want
you to look at the following picture
so we have g
r1
and r2
um so
so far
we've looked at bayesian networks
through the lens of inference where we
know that every variable comes with
a local
conditional distribution but we didn't
worry about where that
came from it was just there
but now for learning it matters where it
came from
so
what we should think about is each of
these variables being powered
by a local conditional distribution so g
is powered by this table here
r1 is powered by this table
and in the case of parameter sharing r2
is also powered by this table
so we have a bayesian network and behind
the scenes you should think about all
these tables which have arrows kind of
hooking up and providing juice to each
of these variables
and now
if you didn't have parameter sharing
then r1 and r2 would be powered by
different tables
now this is an important point when
we're doing inference
you should think about that as reading
from the parameters and when you're
reading you don't care whether
um you have two copies of something or
one copy of something because you're
getting the same thing
but in learning
we're writing to the parameters from the
observed variables
in that case
you need to worry about whether you're
writing to one
a memory location or two memory
locations so the right analogy is you
think about the programming you have
pass by reference or passed by value
and in parameter sharing we're passing
by reference so we're passing this
parameter into each of these nodes and
when we do learning we write back into
those parameters and it matters whether
they're the same
they're uh or not
so
when would you do parameter sharing like
this
well it's a trade-off and it's
ultimately a modeling decision so by
doing this
you aggregate your data which means that
you have more data for parameter which
allows you to get more reliable
estimates on the other hand you end up
with less expressive models
for example if you had
a lot of users you might lose ability to
personalize if you want to share and
there's obviously many of um
intermediate points as well which we
won't get in
so let's look at some other bayesian
networks with parameter sharing so
we already looked at naive bayes before
but just to anchor it in this notation
we have some let's say we have a genre
and we have a movie review
um and we have a asian network which
generates each word
independently conditioned on
the
genre
and so the joint distribution over
everything is equal to probability of
under genre of y times um for each word
the probability word given of a
particular word given y
so the parameters of this page network
are the genre and p word
so now you can think about doing a
little exercise of how many parameters
are there
um
so you look at theta into p genre well
that's two parameters because two genres
keyword that's two times um the number
of
words
that the number of values the wi can
take on
and so
that's it
um so
notice importantly that the number of
parameters does not
grow with l even though the number of
variables in the bayesian network grows
with l so now we see the kind of
complexities of the parameters and the
number of variables to be quite
different you can have a million
variable
bayesian network but you might have only
one parameter for example that's quite
possible so here's another example our
friendly hmm so we have actual positions
of objects h1 through hn and e1 through
en and
this should be very familiar by now so
you have hmm
which has a joint distribution which is
given by
three distributions p start of h one
times transition of h i given h i minus
one times for each variable the
probability of emitting e i given h i
again the parameters are p star p trans
and
and you can think about how many
parameters are in this
bayesian network well you have the
number of positions times number of
positions squared times number of
positions times number of possible
sensor
reading values
okay again there is no dependence on
the time window the number of uh time
steps here and
and this is useful because if you
imagine tracking over a long period of
time you may have a million time steps
you don't want the number of parameters
to be same
okay so
here the training data is going to again
be full assignments to all the random
variables
and
later in a future module we'll come back
to the case where in practice
um you might only observe the sensor
reading but more on that later
so now let's present the general case
hopefully the intuitions have already um
been fleshed out but i just want to
write things down with some formal
notation so
a bayesian network um
remember includes variables x1 through
xn
and
now we have parameters
and the parameters is a collection of
distributions
um so i'm going to write that as p
subscript d
where d indexes into
um some set and for the hmm for example
big d is start trans and min so d is
just a label if you will
name
so each variable x i is generated from
some distribution and now the notation
gets a little bit
scary but it's p sub
d i
is the distribution
that points into x i and i'm taking that
um
looking up that distribution by name
so um you can think about this more
formally as this is just the equation
for defining what evasion network is um
of the joint distribution
those products the local conditional
distributions but now i'm being very
explicit
that each variable
di
every variable i has a particular
distribution that is powering that
variable
so the idea of parameter sharing is that
di is just the same for multiple eyes
okay so here is
the learning algorithm for general
bayesian networks
so the input is a d train consisting of
four assignments to all the variables x1
for xn
and the output is going to be all these
distributions here
so the algorithm is again just count and
normalize so what we're going to do is
go through every training
example which is the full assignment to
all the variables for every
variable in your
basic network we're just going to
increment a counter
okay so what this counter is is
i look at which distribution is powering
variable i
and i'm going to increment
the that counter for
the local configuration which is looking
at
um
assignment to its parents and also the
value of x i
and then i'm just going to normalize for
each distribution and local assignment
to its its parents
i'm going to set the probability under
the distribution of x i given parents to
be proportional
to this count
okay and that's it
so so far we've presented this counter
normalized algorithm shown a lot of
examples and hopefully this seems like a
reasonable thing to do
but
part of you might still be wondering
well why
why is talented normalize a reasonable
thing to do and there
is a higher principle here and it's
called maximum likelihood
so the principle of maximum likelihood
which is a a very old idea in statistics
is that
we have our training data here
okay so we
if we look at the product over all
examples in the training data and we
look at the probability
under the bayesian network that um
that is assigned to that data
and notice i'm going to provide
semicolon theta here
to
recognize the fact that this bayesian
network depends on the parameters now
so this is the likelihood of this data
given these parameters and maximum
likelihood is saying i want to tweak
these parameters so that this likelihood
as large as possible
so this should look a little bit more
like what we were doing in the machine
learning modules where we write down a
loss function which depends on
parameters and and which is usually a
sum over the data and we try to minimize
find the parameters that minimize loss
here it's the opposite we're trying to
find the parameters that maximize
the likelihood
and if you just take a log and you
negate it you actually end up with
minimum loss as well but
i will ignore that for now
so intuitively this is um
a reasonable principle as well what
you're trying to do is for every setting
of parameters that gives you some
likelihood under the model of the data
and you just want to keep on tweaking
that until the likelihood as high as
possible
so
having said that
now i'm just going to claim that that
algorithm which we call counter
normalize is exactly solving the maximum
likelihood objective
so this is really nice because it gives
us a closed solute form solution
to this maximum likelihood objective you
don't have to take the gradient of this
and iterate and worry about convergence
also it's just done and this is one of
the reasons that makes maximum molecular
estimation invasion networks so um
scalable and
you know intuitive is that well it is
available
that was a little bit logical
all right so um i haven't justified why
maximum likelihood principle leads to
the countenance algorithm but let me
just provide you a little bit of a taste
of why this might be the case so let's
take this small data set d4 d5 and c5
so um if i write down the maximum
likelihood objective um so i have two
two variables here
i'm going to expand
that okay so i have max over theta and
theta really here is the probability of
genre
the probability of rating
of given that genre is
c and the probability of writing a given
genre is d
so i have three
distributions here
that i want to
optimize and i'm just expand out based
on the definition of a bayesian network
um
i have probability of a d given for
probability of rating for given d
so that is
the probability
of the first
data point times
p of d
five given d that's the second data
point and then e of c and p of five
given c that's the third data point so
i'm multiplying all these probabilities
across all the data points and that is
the probability
of the data given a particular
assignment to the local conditional
distribution
and now i've color coded them on purpose
because what we can do is we can shuffle
things around
if you just look at probability of g
right so i'm maxing over that
and
that
shows up in these three places and it
doesn't uh affect anything else so i'm i
can just pull that out
and i can pull the green
apart which is up r given c
and can pull the blue stuff out and
that's maximizing over um if r
are given
g equals d here
so
the
punchline here is that we can decompose
the maximum likelihood objective which
looks like a big tangled mess
into actually some problems one for
every distribution and assignments to
the parents of
a particular variable
and now having done that
now i have just one a little local
uh optimization problem here
which is uh basically
a solved by um in closed form
uh you can do this uh i'm not gonna do
this for you but you can introduce a
lagrange multiplier for the sum to one
constraint
and you um do some
uh take some derivatives and you set it
as zero and then you get that
uh the probability max molecular
probability is proportional to the case
here
and in this case what we will estimate
is that um
the probability of d is two-thirds
probably c is one-third and so on
okay so let me summarize now so we've
talked about
learning in fully supervised bayesian
networks where we're observing instances
of all
the variables here
so one important concept to take away is
this idea of parameter sharing
so we have talked about
just a bayesian network
which an inference doesn't care about
where these parameters come from
but we should really think about each of
these nodes as being powered by
a particular
local conditional distribution
and sometimes two variables could be
powered by the same distribution
and again inference is reading from the
parameters right
learning is right into the parameters in
which case
it matters where these arrows come from
so
secondly we looked at the maximum
likelihood principle which is this kind
of high minor principle that says
maximize the likelihood of your data and
we show that this is
equal to this very
pragmatic and simple intuitive principle
of
counting and normalizing
and this is the simplicity which makes
bayesian networks especially naive bayes
still very kind of practical useful and
interpretable
that's the end